[موسيقى]
اغاثه السودان هدف منظمات العمل الانساني
لكن حاله الانفلات الامني المتصاعده منذ
اسابيع تعيق ذلك
صعوبات عده تقف امام منظمات الاغاثه
الدوليه ابرزها احتدام القتال بين طرفي
الصراع رغم الهدن الممتده غياب ضمانات
الامنيه لمسارات قوافذ الاغاثه وصعوبه
تحديد المواقع المتضرره ومن يسيطر عليها
فبين القصف العنيف في العاصمه الخرطوم
ونيران القتال في دارفور تبحث فرق منظمات
الدوليه عن طرق امنه ومسارات تضمن لها
ايصال المساعدات الملحه من الامدادات
الطبيه والغذائيه الى المدنيين العالقين
وبشكل عاجل منظمه اطباء بلا حدود مستوى
العنف الذي سجل في الخرطوم ودارفور ضد
المدنيين ومتطوعي العمل الانساني مقلق اما
عن غياب ضمانات الامنيه فالامم المتحده
ناشدت عده مرات طرفي النزاع من الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريع بتوفير ضمانات امنيه
تحمي قوافل المساعدات بعد تكرر عمليات
النهب بشاحنات مساعد الاغاثيه فوفقا
لبرنامج الاغذيه العالمي التابعي للامم
المتحده ان نحو 17 الف طن من المساعدات
الانسانيه اي ما قيمته نحو 14 مليون دولار
تعرضت للنهب منذ اندلاع القتال في السودان
ومن الصعوبات التي تعرقل عمل منظمات
الانسانيه معرفه من من الطرفين المتنازعين
يحكم سيطرته في تلك المنطقه او تلك سواء
في العاصمه الخرطوم او في دارفور غربا
الامر الذي دفع بعض منظمات الاغاثه الى
التوجه الى مدينه بورتسودان التي تشهد
هدوءا نسبيا واستفوضى في اماكن اخرى
بالبلاد لتصبح المدينه نقطه الدخول
لامدادات المساعدات الدوليه ومركزا لعشرات
الالاف الذين يتطلعون الى الفرار من
القتال
ملوك الشيخ العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات